good morning everyone welcome to yale uh
my name is stuart takeu i'm the program
director for the yale center for
business and the environment and this is
the first environmental marketing
symposium um hosted between the school
of management and the school of forestry
and environmental studies here both dean
snyder at the school of management and
dean crane uh really like to welcome the
audience both here and online apologies
to our audience online we're starting a
little bit late but hello everyone
this um
a couple few people to thank uh before
we begin
we have a fantastic panel of speakers
today
but first this is a component of the
sabin
sustainable venture prize the
sustainable venture prize is a twenty
five thousand dollar winner take all
prize for the best for-profit venture
that comes out of yale university that
supports a more sustainable way of life
and our competition is being held next
thursday we have some of the competitors
actually in the room today who will be
in the final
really looking forward to it and uh this
this marketing workshop and symposium
that has been organized by a couple of
folks who i'll get to in a second is a
component of really hoping to help teach
some of these early stage entrepreneurs
the challenges that they have in um in
marketing products that maybe the people
haven't seen or don't fully understand
so this is
hopefully an attempt to fill that
weapon
eric plunkett
marissa glisia marisa in particular this
was really her brainchild and she was
the one who helped pull this together
bring it forward and before we get
started i'd just like to have a little
round of applause for marissa
we also can't do anything at the yale
center for business the environment
without amy badner who is our event
coordinator and basically makes
everything happen here and puts it all
together amy
typically is not in the room right now
but is running around doing something
else so if you see her please
introduce yourself say hello
and thank her for all her work i'd
appreciate that um and finally we never
really are successful at doing anything
uh at both the school of forestry and
the school of management without the
involvement of our alumni and erica
diamond uh was really someone who
reached out to quite early in the
process to figure out how to pull this
together and she was able to tap into
her network pull us into you know
conversations with people that we
wouldn't normally be able to talk to and
so we really thank erica for helping to
generate enthusiasm and interest amongst
the students and faculty and
administration here in this really
timely and important topic
as well
and with that
i'd like to introduce marissa who's
going to be our mc for today's event
marissa is a first year joint degree
student between the school of management
and the school of forestry and as i
mentioned one of the key research
assistants who's helped been working
with us on initiatives this year so
marissa
hi everyone thanks again for coming
uh for our first presentation we
actually have two speakers um the first
is mae shabbata the chief strategy
officer at think eco which is a leading
provider of cloud-based energy
efficiency and demand response solutions
and the maker of cutting edge energy
savings products like the modlet
and then we also have seth bower
who was not on any of our publications
or invitations but has surprised us
today and we are very excited to have
him um
seth is the vice president of brand
growth at top 10 which is the leading
source of independent information on
energy efficiency of common products and
um
seth and may will be giving a
presentation today on customer interest
and willingness to pay identifying the
right customers for energy efficiency
um so with that may and thank you very
much
thanks marissa
excuse me my name is may shabbat i'm one
of the co-founders of think eco i'm also
their current uh chief strategy officer
before think eco i was the head of
strategy at a large ad agency called
euro rscg in new york so while i can
talk generally about marketing i felt
that maybe today's focus should be more
about our case study kind of show you
what we did and didn't do what worked
what didn't work so you know i want this
to be a fairly open forum um and i'm
basically going to tell you uh how we
went about things and stumbled and all
the lessons learned okay so before i get
started i do want to explain to you just
briefly what our technology is about
because i think it's an important
context so
we have what is an end-to-end platform
so we've got hardware on one end we've
got a software platform on the other and
it's basically an energy management
system for plug loads so anything that
is plugged into an outlet so what you
have is what's called the model at a
modern outlet it plugs into an outlet it
meets your energy use and you can
actually set schedules to save on that
energy use if you're not using something
why don't you shut down power to it you
could also control it remotely from your
iphone for example so that you know if
you want to come home to a cool
apartment you may want to pre-cool your
house you know turn on the window air
conditioner for example so this is the
simplest application of it you know it's
definitely a consumer-oriented product
and that you could use it in your home
but because outlets are ubiquitous
they're everywhere you could use it in a
commercial environment you could use it
anywhere you want so this is um
our platform it's patented
and the reason why we focus on plug
loads is it's actually the largest and
fastest growing source of energy drain
in both homes and offices across america
and if you look at this chart here what
we're looking at is um
commercial office space is growing at
one percent per year okay on a per
square foot basis
and lighting has become more efficient
hvacs have become more efficient
everything else has become so much more
efficient so they're actually decreasing
on a per square foot basis
for energy consumption but all the plug
those are the ones where you know we've
got a lot more computers a lot more
stuff around and so it's growing and
this is important context for what we do
in terms of marketing because this is
not common knowledge
right people think oh i use a lot of
electricity a lot of energy and heating
and cooling
the hvac system lighting yes those were
big problems in the past but right now
actually plug those are the bigger
problem okay
so when we started out our company is
four years old
we
realized that because outlets are
everywhere we could target
residential
commercial spaces as well as the
utilities that provide the electricity
to both of those venues we felt as
consumers at heart
that
the residential environment would be the
best target for our solution because it
is consumer friendly we felt then that
the commercial environment would be a
second good place because of the slide
that i just showed you before where you
know plug load energy use really is
increasing on a per square foot basis we
felt lastly that maybe the utilities
would be a good place to go last and
that
you know there are larger entities
they're more difficult to work with in
terms of figuring out who within the
entity would would be the right person
to work with so this was our hypothesis
going into the whole experience when we
started out the company we'll build we
built our first platform
it turns out when we started
commercializing and learning about the
marketplace that we went about it in a
slightly different order
even though we wanted to do a
consumer-oriented product we
we realized that as a small company it
was cost prohibitive to do so
so we tabled that
instead we went for our second best
option the commercial space and we
targeted them and that was the first
market we went for um and then i'll tell
you why we ended up at the util in the
utilities next
so starting with the commercial space
the platform that we have the model
platform it's easily scaled to any
environment and because the whole
software side is cloud-based it
resides nicely on a corporate network so
you could have different offices in
different locations all supported by a
single network so this is the really the
the pitch if you will that we you know
brought to companies which is it's a
nice retrofit solution you could put it
in this office next office the entire
united states if you wanted to you've
got five offices and all of this is
going to be networked and you're going
to be able to manage your energy use on
plug loads
we had some great data as well so this
is um
these are all plug loads so you can see
the actual devices here this is one
section of one floor of an office and
what you're looking at is data from
midnight to midnight
and power and watts on the y-axis so
what you're seeing is that the green
zones on either end this is when the
office space is empty
okay and there's still that much energy
use going on
so that
what like 800 900 watts you know that's
like 70 percent of the peak daytime use
in other words you're wasting all this
energy at night so for us this was a
fantastic proof point to our client base
that you know the this is real energy
that you could be saving each night you
know after everybody goes home and also
on the weekends and federal holidays
when nobody is in the office
so
scalable solution great savings value
proposition
so with that
we did a couple of uh you know important
things to really validate this value
proposition to our target audience which
are the the businesses so we went crazy
and we did a hundred pilots in a hundred
days um this was
i want to say maybe two and a half years
ago
where we literally targeted we're based
in new york city so we targeted a lot of
the fortune 500 companies there anybody
who said anything about sustainability
about anything green we went to them and
said you know we've got a product we
want you to give it a try
uh you know we will you know measure
your electricity use we'll do the
savings we're going to come up with a
report at the end we'll share the report
with you we're just going to go and do
this you know would you provide your
feedback and we managed to get 100
companies to sign up and we did this in
100 days so that resulted in a report by
us
we called it the eco-empowered report
but we saw a lot of savings across
different types of devices across
different organizations
and it was very powerful from you know
sort of a savings validation standpoint
the technology works it actually does
what it's supposed to do
and so forth what then we did was we did
a joint small business study with
nyserda i don't know if you guys are
familiar with nyserda but they are the
new york state energy research and
development authority they provide a lot
of grants in energy efficiency to
develop technologies to market test
technologies so this was more of a
market testing grant if you will
and the idea here was that you know we
targeted the large companies in the uh
the hundred unit pilot
but this is also a solution that you can
do in a do-it-yourself kind of way right
so it would be perfect for small
business that
you know sub lots of space that you know
occupies a small corner of a large
office space where they can't touch
anything else plug loads are the only
thing
that they can actually do energy
efficiency on so that was the uh the
whole premise there and we did a study
with nyserda we were able to show again
significant savings we were also able to
show engagement so now we were in office
space where you know there there may
only be 12 people so everybody knew what
was going on and when people knew what
was going on they saw the model that
they said huh what is this they saw the
savings and they became you know a lot
more engaged and we saw that the savings
were higher when people were engaged so
that was a nice lesson that we learned
there
and so we took that a little bit further
and said what if we just use this for
employee engagement because people seem
to be really excited about this and you
know in corporate america employee
engagement is a very important part of
you know employee retention loyalty and
so forth so we did this with a company
called grife they're based out in ohio
and
we basically had the models distributed
to employees where they would set it up
they would test they would
use it in their cubicles they would
compete on the basis of savings and the
person who saved the most amount of
energy actually got a
uh like a little trophy at the end so um
we did that initiative and it went and
it went over extremely well okay so
we basically did everything from the
savings validation side of the story to
literally just you know behavioral
employee engagement type stuff
and uh you know we did this over
a year and a half you know this was a
big part of what we were working on
and these were the lessons that we
learned you know from a marketing
standpoint um
even though it was easy to get a hundred
companies to pilot test with us
you know pilot testing is not the same
as purchasing right so when it actually
came to the purchasing stage uh it's a
multi-stakeholder purchase process right
you've got facilities involved because
it you know takes up the actual physical
space you've got sustainability involved
because you know this is about a
sustainability initiative and you have
it involved because we have a software
platform so all of a sudden you know all
three parties needed to sign off which
happened in some cases in other cases
their interests weren't aligned so it
became a really really long sales cycle
unfortunately if when you look at any of
these people
plug load energy management is not top
of anybody's list it's it's a nice to
have you know it's certainly going to
save you real money and it's going to
get you measurable savings from a
sustainability standpoint because plug
loads are such a big you know energy
drain
but from a facility standpoint you know
they're concerned about replacing the
the carpeting if that's what's broken
right from a sustainability standpoint
you know they're looking for that big
headline that they can get out into the
marketplace and i t it's all about
security right why add something that's
gonna
get in the way of security so when you
think about it from last time standpoint
of
letting somebody do their job and doing
it well we hit those hurdles in the
commercial space
customer readiness also varied greatly
the people or i'm sorry the
organizations that were most receptive
to what we had to offer were those that
had already taken measures so they had
taken measures to improve their lighting
they had taken measures to improve their
hvac system and what they realized upon
doing that was they did not get the
energy efficiency gains that they
thought they were going to get they fell
short and so they said what is going on
so these were the people who had done
their own research and realized you know
what we underestimated how much plug
loads actually contribute towards the
energy use in our building and those
were the companies that we didn't have
to educate them they were already there
and the stakeholders were already on
board because they had gone through a
similar process with
some of the other energy efficiency
measures so at the end of the day
where we are as an organization is we do
have some large clients we have some
partners so one of the ones that we
announced recently was our partnership
with accenture which you know is a
business service provider in a lot of
large companies and all of this makes
sense because
of the customer readiness being you know
all over the map if you've got a partner
like accenture in there who already know
who's ready that helps us identify them
and it was something that you know upon
going through this entire exercise for
like one and a half to two years we
realized that yes there is opportunity
in the commercial space it's an early
market and it's very much a targeted
market where it you know for a small
company like us it does not warrant the
resources to just kind of blanket
everybody right and even if you try to
target by size of company type of
company you've got the internal dynamics
that we don't we're just not aware of
until we get there so for us our
strategy was was to basically partner
with somebody who's already always there
who could filter it for us so that's
where we've ended up on the in the
commercial side
so now i'm going to talk about utilities
so this is a completely different market
and as i said in one of the opening
slides this was for us our target number
three of the three markets we thought we
were going for because it seems
complicated i do not have a utility
background and nobody at our company did
at the time when we were getting started
but something funny happened here and
and you know this this ended up being
our success story
so
what we have is a platform that
saves energy from anywhere on anything
that can be plugged into an outlet
right
from that standpoint it's ubiquitous
but when we spoke to khan edison which
is the new york city utilities
they had a killer application for this
we were not aware of it
so
in new york there are 6.3 million window
air conditioners these are the air
conditioners that hang outside windows
yeah you've seen them right i'm sure you
guys have some of them here as well
and uh yeah 6.3 million it contributes
20 percent of summertime electricity
demand in new york it's huge
it overshadows central ac
systems by like four to five fold so
it's the biggest single problem they
have
and if any of you have installed a
window air conditioner you know once it
goes in it ain't coming out until it's
broken right so these things are power
hogs they're old
and there's no way to control them
unless the consumer is there to turn it
on and off themselves
so they looked at our platform and said
well why can we can we use this for
window air conditioners we would love
the control to be temperature based and
we would love to be able to trigger it
when there's a peak electricity demand
day you know during the summer time so
we
worked with khan edison through an r d
partnership where we not only enable the
on off of the window air conditioner but
do so with temperature control so we
added a little bit to our technology
platform
and the reason why khan edison partnered
with us is um
not only was the technology platform
that we already had complementary to
what they wanted
but they saw this as a great marketing
opportunity because we had something
that was so consumer friendly so our gut
instinct going into this company and
starting
out with a very with very much of a
consumer friendly mindset actually
helped us to secure this utility deal
because they didn't want to do anything
that seemed
industrial grade right they wanted
something that consumers would want to
adopt on their own
so what we provided to the consumer
was the ability to remotely control
their window air conditioner from their
smartphone right so if you forgot to
turn off your air conditioner as you
left your house you could do it from
your smartphone and you could save
energy by doing that or as i said in the
earlier example you could pre-cool your
home 15 minutes before you come home
it's a great consumer benefit and if you
actually set schedules to you know keep
your air conditioner off while you're
out of the house you're going to save
real money so that dual benefit the real
benefit to the utility to be able to
reduce peak demand and the benefit to
the consumer of this being you know
something that they could really use was
what uh you know helped this this
opportunity so as you can see when we
actually rolled it out into the market
space um we launched this three years
ago so now we're in year three
we uh
definitely took on a very consumer
friendly uh feel to the whole thing we
branded it cool nyc we came up with a
program name so we said okay you know
what we have is the technology right
what we have is a product actually as
far as a consumer is concerned but if
you're going to try to get people to
sign up to help reduce electricity for
the utility it needs to be a program it
needs to be something that people belong
to it's not just about a product that
they have so we
called it cool nyc we trademarked it we
came up with a website and as you can
see on the web from the screenshot of
the website here we have all the valley
propositions right across the middle it
helps you stay connected it helps you to
cool in a much more smart kind of way
and it lets you check in from anywhere
in terms of energy use and in terms of
how you're using your air conditioners
we rolled this out through retail as
well
so
you know our customer is con edison so
they pay help to pay for the product and
to offset costs but we wanted to get it
into people's hands in a way that was
natural to them
and we thought the best way to do that
was to do it through retail so we
offered it through retail at best buy at
eight best buy stores in new york city
where people could buy it for 69.99 the
moment they sign up online they would
get a 25
e-gift card so that would incentivize
them to do that they would use this
product all summer long and at the end
of the summer they would get another 25
back so we created this this ecosystem
where we had a retail partner you know
we had a program in place
and
we also had people sign up on their own
so um in certain targeted neighborhoods
we really wanted people to you know to
use a product so we um you know did
recruitment events at green markets and
other places where you know we could get
into the local communities and as you
can see from the uh the growth here and
in terms of people signing up and using
the product you know we had a really
successful summer and when we talked to
people at the beginning when they you
know first got the product
the values that they were talking about
were preventing blackouts making it
easier to use electricity and making a
difference so you know they were
motivated by a desire to um
to do the right thing and uh you know
that was interesting for us to see
so having done all of this you know we
got a program in place we got people
sign up we got people to purchase we got
people basically using the product
the ultimate value to con edison is that
we got a load that we can now control so
what you're looking at the histogram on
the left hand side shows the load curve
of all the units that we have under
management and as you can see you know
the average is about a thousand watts so
you know there's that there's
significant room to actually curtail use
during a hot summer day
and what you're looking at on the right
hand side is when we actually did an
event where it's a called a conservation
event but we basically asked we you know
have people shut off their ac's for a
short period of time or change the step
temperature and what you see is the
difference between the baseline of where
the energy use would have been to what
was actually used so this helps to keep
the grid more reliable on a really hot
day
an interesting thing that happened along
the way is you know as i said you know
when people first sign up it was all
about um you know helping kindness and
doing the right thing and so forth
we asked them at the end of the summer
what they actually did
and it turns out people seem to have
gotten a lot more out of it okay so 18
said that they told their friends to
save energy as a result of using the
model and seeing how much energy their
window air conditioners use
22 percent said they use their lights
less because they became more aware
you know the correlation between energy
use and dollar you know spent on
electricity
52 said they used their ac less after
seeing this energy use not surprising
60 said that they now turn off or unplug
their unused devices so you know they
kind of thought about other electronics
you know what else is using electricity
in my home
and ninety percent want to re-enroll in
column yc again next year which is
actually now this year okay so
an interesting thing happened here where
you know the consumer was not aware of
this product it was introduced to them
through con edison through the cool nyc
program that we had put into place we
basically lowered the hurdle for
adoption for people but once they
started using it we saw all the effects
that we thought we would see amongst the
consumer base
so the lessons learned here is that uh
you know from
who is the right target audience who is
the right purchaser
the fact that there was a killer
application for these window air
conditioners in new york city really
enable this utility partnership to take
hold a lot faster than we would have
otherwise expected and you know i think
it's it's true to say that this is a
partnership yes con edison is our
customer but you know we work with them
on so many levels that you know we we do
treat each other as partners and i think
that was key
that in order to get you know a utility
to actually buy into something like this
that we actually provide value on a
level of a partner
the dual benefit you know as i alluded
to earlier the fact that we actually do
demand reduction for utilities and
provide a consumer benefit in terms of
you know the remote control ability of
your window air conditioners was key for
adoption obviously
and you know i believe that our success
was just as much about as as marketing
as it was about technology right the
fact that it was a fun program to be a
part of and they got a product that you
know lived up to its promise if you will
so that consistency the the trust was
something that we believe you know
really made a difference so for us you
know as we kind of journeyed through
targeting commercial customers and
ending up working with utilities by far
you know working with utilities was the
right right target audience for us but
now that we've had some success with
consumers you know having done a
cool nyc
we obviously want to do more right
so
now we are retail available we're
available at best buy walmart amazon and
a couple of local chains and what you
see here is you know an ad that you know
you might see on your uh on a website if
you were looking for something some sort
of energy saving product
so
um yeah we've been retail available for
a little over a year at best buy and you
know really amazon and walmart like
literally over the last like three or
four months okay so this is brand new
for us
what we have in our favor is we get we
have great media buzz
we have been in hundreds of publications
uh mass media over the last couple years
we've been on national tv
about ten times
um you know last year we were on cnn
money during the summer you know new
york one sort of you know
we do manage to get the word out which
is fantastic for a company our size and
if you're trying to do consumer
marketing all of that stuff is important
now as i said we're early in this market
and in terms of our lessons learned
media mentions do drive sales we
definitely see a blip
but it's a short-lived blip okay
awareness is clustered geographically we
get a lot of sales in new york a lot in
california uh you know there are
definitely pockets where you might
expect
energy efficiency products to take off
and we're certainly seeing traction
there
we're also seeing a lot of nothingness
in a lot of the other parts of the
united states
so for us you know it's been a real
question how to scale this cost
effectively if at all
and this is the reason why you know we
brought seth bauer along for this part
of the presentation because you know
from our standpoint as a single
organization we feel that you know we've
seen it through cool nyc if consumers
actually give it a try and use it they
get the full value out of it they're
more likely to tell their friends and it
you know we hope that it sort of
snowballs but to just get onesies and
twosies sale you know two consumers
we're not quite sure that you know how
we're going to get there so
i think at this point i want to bring
seth up and you know he's got a lot more
experience in the consumer retail space
thank you
i actually want to
go back from there
hi i'm seth bauer from top 10 usa
um
i am clearly a terrible marketer because
i didn't even manage to get marissa to
understand that i was coming and talking
here today so
i wouldn't actually listen to anything i
say over the next few minutes
top 10 is kind of a
consumer reports for energy efficiency
and so so we look at products from an
energy efficiency standpoint and we try
to introduce that
into the consumer conversation
the consumer mindset consumer decision
and then
see if we can get manufacturers to
compete to innovate
to be ever more efficient by recognizing
you by creating basically top 10 lists
of the most efficient
whatevers
but getting energy efficiency into the
conversation is no
easy task and i'm going to talk ab about
this today from the perspective of a
shopping journey so how you as a
consumer
uh think about go about buying products
and
where you know energy efficiency might
or might not become part of that
equation
i've spent a fair amount of time
thinking about
consumers and green decisions uh and i
come out of the media world
i uh for a long time was a magazine
editor including a head of a group at
national geographic called the green
guide which was really the first attempt
by national geographic to
move from
uh
offering inspiration to care about the
environment to offering practical advice
about how to live in the environment um
and so you know every
cover line on a magazine is a marketing
decision
uh and we think about them very
carefully we test them we play with them
uh we get feedback after the fact
and so every little bit of wording
about how to
think in a green way why what's going to
motivate you why you might care
is reflected in in a magazine cover and
so you look at things you know words
like first of all you look at numbers
you always try to get numbers on a
magazine cover because for some reason
people like lists
which i now relate to my top 10 work
you look at uh what the personal payoff
is
um you look at cooling your home with
less energy maybe i should have
shown you that one earlier
you look at being safer
you look at what the personal payoff is
for someone and that's true in any
marketing context
so now i'm going to talk about what the
modern
shopping journey is like and it is uh
it's changed
it's changing rapidly and it really is a
journey uh of inputs expectations what
you care about and then what you get out
of it
so imagine that your refrigerator is
broken and and i i found this
awesome 1970s refrigerator
and i had one of those
first in my house and then in my garage
for a long long time and once you learn
anything about energy efficiency one of
the things you learn is having a
refrigerator in your garage especially
an old tired one is about the stupidest
thing you can do
so your refrigerator is broken
but
shoppers are no longer shoppers you no
longer just go into a store
and say okay i want to replace a
refrigerator you are a multi-channel
consumer
nowadays and every uh big consulting
firm on earth is looking at retail from
the perspective of multi-channel so if
you're going to learn anything about
retail start with the code word
multi-channel so this is from
pricewaterhousecoopers
when i was
pulling this together i saw reports from
mckinsey from forester from
basically everybody you can think of
looking at the
multi-channel
shopping experience
and what multi-channel means is that you
are going to combine your
social
networking life
your online or connected life
and uh your
time
shopping uh you know your time in actual
brick and mortar stores and you're gonna
use it in all kinds of
different ways
uh so i'm gonna buy my new
uh refrigerator and maybe the first
thing i'm going to do is call
my friend may ciabatta who has uh and i
was going to surprise her with this
slide and then i sent her my deck last
night so she she was on to this but
maybe i'm going to call may
and ask her um
what she knows about refrigerators
because i know may's a very intelligent
person and i know she works in the
energy efficiency space and maybe she's
actually going to know something about
that and if she doesn't her daughter
probably is because she's really smart
uh maybe i'm gonna go online and i'm
going to post something to my hundreds
of facebook friends to see if any of
them
have learned anything about
refrigerators lately you know know
something that i don't i and
and actually i i just tried this i tried
to sort of crowdsource information
recently i'm i'm taking a business trip
next week to beijing
and i haven't been there before and so i
posted something on facebook
and you know i figure among my many
friends
i'm sure a lot of them have traveled
over there before
and i got like
four snarky comments and absolutely no
useful advice whatsoever so
i'm now getting a little dubious but i
might post something on facebook saying
do you know anything about refrigerators
and then while i'm there i'm gonna look
and notice that my college roommate had
posted a graduation picture from the
early 80s on the yale campus
and that fuzzy person on the right with
the fuzzy hair is me
the next thing i'm going to do is is
look electronically
and among these various studies by these
big consulting firms just enormous
numbers of consumers
include online research now as part of
their buying decision so 88
say they research via their pc although
one thing that's interesting about that
is
even in this uh you know smartphone
and tablet
happy society
the the numbers around doing product
research are still concentrated on the
on the pc on the laptop or the desktop
and maybe it's because the screens are
too small or the the connection's not as
fast or something but people aren't
actually going to google very often and
trying to do product research
on their phones yet
so okay now i'm now i'm in this
electronic world what am i going to do
i'm going to go to a retail site i'm
going to see what sears
has
uh but then i start worrying about you
know
is this the right decision so i'm going
to go back to google
and i'm going to search for um
some kind of third party validation for
the decision i'm considering
making and again there's a lot of
research that says
consumers who who research online
research on retail sites and then also
look for independent
validation for their decisions and
that's
really that you know that's my current
business that's what top 10 is all about
so i type in refrigerator rankings
and i get a list of things consumer
reports not surprisingly comes up first
jd power comes up second
but uh thank god
somewhere on this first page
is top 10 usa
and it has the words energy efficient
large refrigerators and that is the
first time so if you looked at the sears
site if you looked on facebook if you
uh called may ciabatta
that one
may or may not be true she probably
would talk about energy efficiency um
energy efficiency has not been part of
the conversation yet
and this is the moment
really when it gets introduced
and this is what
i am focusing on
as a way to
start to create that consumer demand for
truly
efficient products because we just waste
so much for so for no reason i mean most
of the energy that we waste
we waste uh
because we don't think about it
basically probably because it's too
inexpensive to care about you know
you're only paying whatever 18 cents a
kilowatt hour
um
so we introduce
energy efficient
into the conversation and you click on
that
and
you have what i hope is a really
easy to use robust website that just
tells you what the 10 most efficient
products are in all of these various
product categories
but the message to consumers
is not necessarily
saved by this product and save energy
and if you think about
your consumer experience
we buy things for all kinds of reasons
and we get all kinds of rewards from
buying products we get the we get the
utilization of the product
um but we also get status
we get there's a little you know some
chemical biochemical mix that happens
when you buy something you get a little
jolt of of
whatever it is happy juices
when you buy something
uh
the consumer experiences is uh an
emotional and visceral
experience and the consumer reward is
beyond oh i'm going to save a few
pennies on my energy bill so so there
has to be a message that is
beyond
the dry message of efficiency
and into the message of this is exciting
so so i'm um
i'm on a one-man campaign so far it's
one man campaign
uh with the led
lighting industry to start a a got milk
style
advertising campaign
where
uh
led lighting
is really its superior light i mean
there's a reason why museums are
using it to light their paintings and
there's a reason why
martha stewart uses it and i used to
work for martha so i know this
you know uses it in her offices and is
starting to use them in her home
and so i want to say not
those
expensive little leds are more efficient
you should buy them i want to say this
is the light of the future and if you
don't have this
you know you're behind the times you can
put yourself in the best light you can
see your
your
kitchen counter in museum quality light
and i have some interest
from the led side but also from the um
utility world
in maybe creating a big campaign around
this
so that's one message to consumers
another messages to consumers is
um
you know be smart you know like
we we often talk about
um
we talk about energy consumption
as sort of an evil in and of itself and
really for most of us it's not you know
environmentalists talk about it as an
evil in and of itself but for most of us
energy efficiency
is
you know it's a it's a lesser
form of motivation lesser form of
interest but we all hate waste
we all hate wasting things
and an environmentalist hates wasting
things a you know climate change
non-believer hates wasting things if you
frame
the
uh
the proposition
in a more universal
way and you actually say you know you
have a little fun with it
um there's an opportunity to actually
get consumers engaged
so i actually did i i did and i was
going to if this were more of a
classroom i was going to ask you guys to
brainstorm i
i have done a top 10 list
and i don't pretend to be a david
letterman
writer but i sort of took advantage of
the fact that he does these top 10 lists
all the time
and said okay what are the top 10
reasons
to choose energy efficient products
and i
tried
i tried to be humorous i didn't try to
be funny but i think it would be a
worthy exercise to try to be funny i
think there could be a really good list
here so
anyone wants to take on that assignment
just email me
because everybody's a closet david
letterman writer i know that
so so back to your consumer shopping
experience so you you're on our site and
you can drill down
very quickly to
what the top products are
uh you can price them you can see if
they are available at brick and mortar
stores
near you you can see if your utility is
offering
a rebate
we want to we're not spending a lot of
time selling energy efficiency we want
to get you to make a
consumer purchasing decision as
seamlessly as possible for the right
reason because if it's on our site it's
an energy efficient product
so then what are you going to do you're
going to actually
consider
going to stores and this is a huge
phenomenon
and it cuts both ways where consumers
will research online but they still want
to go
have the in-store experience they want
to see things you know see the actual
product before they buy it
so they they research online but they
don't buy online and so if you look at
big statistics about you know consumer
online retail online retail is still
less than 20 or something of total
retail and online retail for things like
appliances is about seven or eight
percent
so there aren't big inroads there there
is still
an actual store
involved although
uh what these consulting firms are
saying is there might not be stores in
the way that we know stores now for very
long where we expect to go in
and they have the product in stock
and um
we take it you know we put it in the
back of our car and and bring it home
the prediction is that stores are going
to be much more showrooms where you can
play with things so some more kind of
the apple store
model where you know you can play you
can look
but
where you actually buy it and how it's
delivered
may not be very directly related to
that store experience
all right so you bring home your
refrigerator and it still looks like a
1970s model but now it's very 2013
because you're actually wearing a glass
globe
on your head this was a
this is an ad from the early 70s about
sort of the the kitchen of the future
and i'm not sure why women are supposed
to wear fish balls now but
apparently here in the future we should
all be wearing fishbowls on our head
and hopefully
oh and there's earrings too i don't know
what those earrings do they're really
cool though but hopefully lots of people
are going to do this
and lots of people are going to elevate
energy efficiency to the top and lots of
people are going to have
top 10
super efficient
models of appliances
and why and that
then
uh this guy on the right is the
president of bosch
um who i've met with a couple of times
and then he's going to be really excited
about making the next
top 10 list
um and
if you look at uh i'm gonna
make you as hyper aware of this as i am
now which
i apologize for in advance
as you're looking at consumer ads in
various media look at how many of them
mention a jd power
award they're jd power award winners for
cars for insurance companies for
products um
consumers have no idea i don't think
who jd power is
do people in this room know what jd
power is as an entity or what they do
um
you don't need to you trust you've heard
it before and you trust that this is a
big deal or the manufacturer wouldn't be
growing about it
or the insurance company wouldn't be
growing about it that's where we're
trying to get top ten and we want this
guy on the right
to
actively be saying okay what can we
build that is going to put us on next
year's
top 10 list
how can we improve the efficiency of our
refrigerator so that we're on that
list
and here's why it matters the fact is
i'm going to go forward one and then
come back the fact is this is pretty
much the only
indication that most consumers have
about any form of energy efficiency does
it have that turquoise
energy star
label and what energy star energy star
is a government program it's run through
the epa
currently
um
and it sets minimum standards for higher
efficiency
products and any
products that meet its baselines can
carry that
energy star tag
what energy star hasn't really gone out
of the way to
publicize nor has
any of the manufacturers because it's
really not in their interest
is there is a huge margin between
something that just meets that energy
star baseline
and something that is
identical size often from similar
manufacturers similarly priced
similarly featured but is at the top of
the efficiency curve so this is a chart
showing the difference between
a standard suite of products a
television a computer a dishwasher
clothes washer refrigerator
and a uh
that just barely meet the energy star
qualifications
and uh the same products
from the same level of manufacturers and
and one of the things that we do at top
10
is we
have a um and is this product actually
for sale in the marketplace
uh test
because a lot of times uh you'll see a
list of super efficient products and you
go to buy one and they are nowhere to be
found they're discontinued they're back
ordered they're
uh they're only sold in canada i mean
there are all kinds of there 20 reasons
why
you know a government energy star list
only has about
40 percent of the products that are
actually available so we screen for that
so you can save
you know just through your everyday
consumer choices
you can save you know almost half the
electricity
you're using now on your most commonly
used
uh electric goods
um
if anybody in this room knew that
besides me
uh you know walking in here i would be
amazed
and that's what really you know that's
what top ten
is here to do back at that google page
we want to introduce energy efficiency
into the conversation
so that
and get you excited about it by pointing
out that
it's stupid to waste electricity and
that you can put yourself in the best
light with the best choices
to move you from that left hand column
to the right hand column
so that is your
new shopping
journey
involving
all kinds of places where energy
efficiency can get introduced into the
conversation and i think
probably as as we turn this over to
later speakers
you'll see how some people are trying to
reinforce that message from other
perspectives
thanks
okay yeah we'd like to open the floor up
for questions so um
i guess me and
um seth if you want to stay up here and
um eric will come around and give you a
microphone to just say your name and
where you're from before you answer ask
the question
thanks
so actually one thing that i
had written to marissa in that email
that she didn't get so she didn't know i
was here
is that i i grew up in new haven and i
went to yale as an undergrad so this is
kind of a homecoming for me so thanks
for
thanks for giving me the time
um hi may thanks for
your presentation my name is apparent
i'm a second year graduate student here
at the school of forestry uh so i have a
couple of questions related though
what is the average deal size of your
commercial customer
what is the average sales cycle
you know the sales cycle time and also
did you benchmark uh your adoption rates
with other new
energy-saving technology companies and
how did you fare
the answer to the last question is no we
have not benchmarked um in terms of
average deal size
to if you're looking at a large
commercial space with multiple floors an
entire building for example it's it's
really easy to get to like a one-floor
deployment you know everybody wants to
test things right and and businesses are
no exception so
we can usually get to a full floor
deployment in just a couple of meetings
really you know so depending upon do you
meet them every week or every other week
you know it sort of changes that but
really the the hardest part of the
adoption is then going to scale right so
you know we've got
one a big organization out in california
where they've done a floor they've done
a building now are they going to do all
20 of their buildings i mean that is a
multi-year process
we don't disclose average deal size
thanks for being here guys i really
appreciate it um my name is jeff
woodward i'm a second year student both
in the school of forestry and school of
management
um may i'm curious about how you message
the demand response component of your
program to customers just because
i think people
it just seems complicated like you're
going to control my ac you're not going
to control my ac
how did you get over some of those
hurdles with folks it is definitely hard
and uh you know it does not come up in
the first conversation because they're
still trying to understand what it is
that i can do with it right so in the
first conversation it's very much about
you can control your window air
conditioner from your smartphone you
know or like you could
save energy on your window air
conditioner
where the demand response comes up is we
actually call it a conservation event
which i think just you know intuitively
makes more sense to to consumers
so where the conservation event concept
comes up is
when people sign up to the program they
have to sign a form that says i am
participating in the program the program
consists of
running a couple of conservation events
so that's where it gets introduced so
it's definitely part of the second
conversation it's within the context of
a conservation event and we message to
people before the event so 24 hours
before an event we say tomorrow
electricity use in new york city is
going to be extremely high
we would like to set the temperature on
your ac a couple of degrees higher if
you're okay with it you don't need to do
anything if you're if you're you know if
you don't want to participate go here to
opt out and then we do the same reminder
again two hours prior so we keep kind of
messaging it so that they're at every
moment in time there's absolutely no
surprise about what's going on
and we make sure that people feel a part
of it right so after an event is done we
then message people back and say thank
you very much for your participation we
were able to reduce usage by x percent
and that way we kind of close the loop
back again
commercial energy users
who have on-site generation
often have an agreement with their power
suppliers for
interruptible power during peak periods
and that's lowers their electric rate
it's a contractual rate for the year
is there any uh
inroads with con ed to introduce this
system into the residential market for
use with your product in the residential
and
sorry to use a product in a residential
environment yeah for your air
conditioning interruption would there be
a benefit for the consumer if if con ed
were to restructure their electric rates
reduce them on an annual basis to allow
them to interrupt the power
to the air conditioner
and not at this point
everything that you know for example con
edison does with their customers has to
go through the public service commission
process so at this point you know this
is a voluntary program where it's you
know incentivized that way
to your point though about uh you know
in the commercial space we have been
looking into cycling different types of
electronics to help people stay within
you know a certain usage so that you
know if you're a commercial client you
don't have such high demand charges even
if you're not structured under the type
of scenario you're talking about
actually just a quick comment on that
there are some places in the country now
where
residential prices are
demand based they vary with demand
um with the the think eco program and
the modlets for the for the ac
system that you did with con ed there
did you have an average kilowatt hour
savings per user that signed up for the
program did you have that metric i'm
curious did you also calculate in the
server usage of energy that's used
to to do the campaign how much energy is
it costing you to send out all these
email reminders and the process of using
these devices
thank you we have not quantified that um
i know that we've done it on a general
level you know just having modlets out
there
and you know it's it still saves
significant energy despite all that
we've also done a whole calculation in
terms of you know the carbon that's used
from the manufacturing to then how much
is saved and so forth
in terms of the energy saving through uh
the cool nyc program there are two types
of savings so number one is during the
peak right the conservation events that
we were talking about the average demand
reduction during all the conservation
events we've run is 25 percent and
that's across all air conditioners
whether they're actually on at the
beginning of an event or you know
they're just there right so
that is a very significant
level of demand reduction again if
you're thinking about 6.3 million window
air conditioners you know more than a
thousand watts each that is you know
if you could enroll even 10 of window
air conditioners you might be able to
you know offload the capacity of like a
medium-sized plant so it's you know it's
it's a lot of
savings there in terms of consumer
driven savings so these are people who
set savings schedules so they keep their
air conditioner off when in the past
they would have left it on all day long
that varies all over the map
because you know some people put
schedules in place some people had
already religiously turned things on and
off
but we did note that
last summer people saved anywhere from
on the low end 60 during the summer to
on the high end fourteen hundred dollars
so the range is huge
and as a result of the range being so
large
we actually do not message that
we don't want people to be you know
disappointed by their savings if they're
on the lower end of the average we also
don't want to
you know p well if you know you've got a
big air conditioner you're going to
think you're going to save more and we
don't want to disappoint those people
either by showing them an average that's
you know artificially low so those are
numbers that we
have but we
we feel that that's not going to be a
motivating factor
i'm sorry i think that we need to wrap
up now but i'm sure that may shavata and
seth bauer will both be around to follow
up with any additional questions
afterwards
please join me in thanking them again
for two really interesting presentations
on how to promote energy efficiency we
really appreciate you coming
um now just to try to get back on
schedule let's take a five minute break
and then we'll come back in for
a talk from marta kirsis of recyclebank
thank you
okay
actually get started again i also just
wanted to thank a couple of students who
have really helped me put all this
together
i could not have organized this
conference without katherine wright
natalie
plunkett so thank you all and also thank
you anthony clark for jumping in and
helping us deal with these technical
issues um sorry we're a little bit
continually behind schedule today but um
you know technology is what is it so
our next speaker is marta kirsis the
vice president of insights at
recyclebank
we had a slight change of plans at the
last second and though you may have seen
that kate durkin would be here
we are very excited to have marta in her
place
recycle bank gets people engaged on
environmental issues from recycling to
energy use by rewarding people for
taking everyday green actions
with discounts and deals from local and
national businesses it was one of fast
companies 50 most innovative companies
in
2012.
marta oversees all market research based
initiatives for the company she joined
recyclebank in 2010 and leads the charge
in understanding how to motivate
behavior change among eco-curious
mainstream consumers before joining
recyclebank marta was director of
digital strategic insights and research
for mtv networks in this role she
focused on interplay of technology media
and advertising
she holds a bachelor of arts with honors
in sociology and anthropology from
colgate university
marta
hello thanks for having me today
apologize for the delay we were hoping
to have some video
and fingers crossed we may have it uh
but we'll continue on
um it's always a journey and
you know it seemed to be a theme in the
first presentation today and continue to
weave it out uh in my presentation as
well
but i would first like to start off with
having everybody stand
stretch those legs a little bit
all right
so please keep standing if you consider
yourself to be a frequent recycler
so what i mean by that is that you're
really diligent about making sure that
you're sorting your recycling from your
waste and getting it to the curb
whenever you can
excellent not surprising i thought i'd
be in a room with some pretty greenies
keep standing if you
regularly recycle the products that you
use in your bathroom
so what i mean by that is when you
finish using the shampoo bottles your
conditioner bottles the soap bottles you
make sure to recycle those as well
pretty good not surprising
um please keep standing
if you are diligent about recycling your
batteries your old cell phones and
or computers
or you're like me
who
i really really want to
i have them in my drawer but they're
sitting there collecting dust because
i'm just not quite sure how and when the
right time to do it is
excellent
and last
please keep standing if you've ever
heard of recycle bank before today's
symposium
you can all sit down now
so give yourself an applause for a bit
of participation thank you very much
but ultimately the goal of that exercise
was really to show that we're all on a
journey
and particularly as it relates to
sustainable action and green actions um
and this journey is really what a theme
that will weave itself through the
presentation today and i think seems to
be an overarching theme that we will
address today so
thank you for joining on that on that
journey
um
so today i'm here to focus on how we
connect our online lives with our
offline lives but first i really want to
take a step back
and talk about the genesis
of the recycle bank idea
you know here today we're talking about
marketing and particularly in the green
space
and the basic marketing principle is
really to think about uh fulfilling a
need or a desire
you know looking whether it be from a
utilitarian perspective or an emotional
standpoint
and ultimately where recycle bank
stemmed from was
two students in business school
in the early 2000s and at the time it
was just after 9 11 and new york city
was under a severe budget crisis
they are dealing with the aftermath of
the towers falling uh they were in uh
fiscal constraints and we started to
take away
many of the items or materials that we
were recycling up until that date
and so it was a very much an emotional
response to how could this happen
something that um i have emotional
connection to
that i think is doing something better
for the world is all of a sudden being
taken away from me
and so they sought out to really help to
solve this problem and dilemma
now every marketing
solution really should be founded in an
insight
and particularly with insight it tends
to be very
backward or like past facing but really
we need to turn the lens on that and and
look at it from a forward-facing
perspective
and so
what we do is we begin to look at the
market challenges and and determine what
the insight is from there uh to figure
out what is the real opportunity we knew
that there was this emotional
detachment that was happening that
created this want and desire to figure
out how to make recycling uh
more possible to the masses but really
what was the marketplace challenge and
so we've done a bit of a deep dive into
that
in the u.s there is over 132 million
household units
but
only 50 percent of households actually
have access to recycling
that's a huge huge gap and a part of
that really stems from infrastructure
but when we took a deeper dive into the
actual recycling habits we're seeing
that only 18 percent of materials that
are able to be recycled are recyclable
and ultimately we determined that this
is where we wanted to put our focus
while we could start to think about
infrastructure and work with and work
with governments to help to alleviate
those problems really we wanted to be a
consumer-facing
product in which to really help to
understand and bring to the forefront
and how to really get to motivate
change as it relates to sustainable
behaviors
at the same time when we thought about
how do we increase recycling rates and
how do we
look to motivate people to change
everyday behavior we wanted to take a
cross look at consumer behavior in
general and so we ultimately were able
to seize upon a mainstream
uh movement
so we took a cross-section of just green
attitudes and behaviors across the uh
u.s
population
and this stems from actually a third
party research
from bbmg
and it takes a really cross look about
the essentially the journey that
consumers are on as it relates to
sustainable behaviors and ultimately
what we came across and the insight that
we pretty much are driving towards is
really speaking to that 60 in the middle
that are somewhere on their green
journey so we realize that there's about
30 percent of the population out there
that will never ever be have any
greenness in their mindset and their
attitudes and their behaviors and
ultimately will never change uh what
they're actually wanting to do
as well as there's about 15 of the um
of the audience out there consumers out
there that are very very dark green i'm
sure that many of you fall into this
bucket but where we really saw the
ability to be able to create a mass
change
was in that 60 in that middle
um and when we dived deeper we wanted to
really understand what were the hurdles
among the 60 percent that really they
didn't why they weren't incorporating
more green actions into their life and
ultimately what we found and the insight
that we were very much based upon is
78
of consumers say they would do more if
they understood how a particular green
action could have helped the environment
as well as benefit them personally
to date you know as we let as we let up
to you know the early 2000s and and into
the into the
2000s really many of the tactics that
had been used were of a threatening
nature they were
you know you had uh stats thrown at you
that weren't easily digestible or
understandable
words that unless you were familiar with
in the in the industry or you know
deeply embedded you had no idea what
they meant and so it was a very scary
threatening place in which to start to
tap tap into and you know put your toes
into the water there
so
what we have you know what we have done
is turn that on its side and really
thought about how do we make
the information that people are seeking
both in a fun
easy digestible manner which is
relatable but also seamless into their
lifestyles so we fully acknowledge that
environmental issues are not at the
forefront of everyday person's life one
doesn't wake up and think about the
impact uh you know top of mind impact of
the impact that they're having and the
environment that you know on the
environment really what they're
interested in is getting their kids out
the door making sure that they're fed
making sure that they can pay their
bills
um and so you know the challenge that's
been posed to us is really how do we
make how do we insert this dialogue
seamlessly into their lives
so ultimately recycle bank stands at the
forefront of interplay between green
technology and social
we've come up with a very bold and
aspirational mission statement and
ultimately i'll read it to you word for
word so we seek to motivate individuals
and communities to realize a world where
nothing is wasted
now we understand that you know this is
very broad reaching and far-reaching but
it you know it has two particular
insects intersects in which we're both
speaking to individuals as well as
communities and how do we play that in
out in the green space with all the
evolutions and innovations that are
happening in technology today
ultimately what recycle bank does it
rewards people for taking everyday green
actions so whether it be recycling
energy reduction water conservation
more greener
transportation options
and looking to
have a personal recognition around that
through our point system as well as
rewarding them with our with our catalog
of deals and discounts um to help you
know reward per a person for taking
those actions and really moving along
down that that path that journey that
they're taking to be uh to lead greener
lives
so ultimately recycle bank is in a
trifecta where we engage communities we
work with municipalities
and community members and to bring the
recycle bank program to uh communities
and engage them at a very local level
we partner with brands uh and innovate
uh both of both our product but as well
as the marketing messaging and what how
to
speak to consumers
about sustainability
through the lens that they're on a
journey
and lastly we look to motivate members
in which we motivate them through our
platform
through educational and incentive
programs
so here was supposed to be the first
video but i have a sense we didn't get
it up running so um
ultimately i'm going to do a little bit
of a deep dive into uh what the value of
community communities have with
recyclebank
so ultimately
it doesn't play right oh oh it's playing
but no sound
um
so ultimately what we have here is um
recycle bank is seen by communities as a
way to
help
reach its sustainability goals
so
are there any new yorkers in the room or
native new yorkers in the room
so would you like to garner or guess
where your trash goes
when you're living in new york or when
it's picked up in new york
staten island used to so uh currently
it's being transported to both
pennsylvania and ohio
so you can imagine both the
sustainable impact or the environmental
impact that that transportation has but
also all the costs that are involved in
that transportation as well as the
addition of landfill fee landfill fees
so
it behooves communities really to look
for cost savings in terms of being able
to divert
recyclables from the waste stream
means that less waste is going into the
landfill and thereby decreasing their
landfill fees but also there's the
opportunity to
generate revenue from the commodities
there is a commodities market for paper
glass
plastics
and in which they are able to really
capitalize on
and bring revenue to their bottom line
this is a picture of
a launch in fort worth texas
in particular you see
us really starting to make headway as it
relates to
areas in the south east and southwest
particularly in the mindset of really
being able to impact their bottom lines
here we have the mayor and her her
glorious red jacket
she had pearls and diamonds on him that
day and we actually this was our launch
event and we there was we went in and we
actually opened up bags of trash as an
example to show how much is actually not
getting diverted into recycles and we
pulled out cans of aluminum we pulled
out plastic bottles there was paper
cardboard in there it was amazing to
think to see how much just in these
three four random bags of trash that we
had
you know how much was still really in
there and ultimately fort worth
estimates that they are you know they
currently could be saving
13 million
dollars per year
just on the commodities themselves and
so this is you know a new rollout in
which
you know we've begun a strong
partnership with them
but to that end uh communities really
see
us being able to be their marketing
platform
ultimately they have the infrastructure
the communities have the infrastructure
for uh picking up the recycling and then
the overlay recycle bank in which to be
able to communicate with their residents
so many times we go into meetings and we
talk about you know ways that we can
partner with each other and the
community the community council members
very much acknowledge the you know that
they need to have uh be communicating
with their residents where they are so
whether it be on facebook or twitter
um or other um outlet
you know so uh
online channels
and really they're just not capable at
this point in time to put the resources
to that so they really see us being able
to overlay our marketing expertise uh
through our email channel uh through our
through our
on the ground activation events as well
as our online and social media outlets
to be able to
one get the word out about the program
but also
to be able to get the knowledge about
about what is actually recyclable in
their local
communities that is the number one ask
that we get from members is really this
understanding of what when where
is recyclable in my community and we are
seen as that outlet and communication
channel
in which to do that
so now sort of to the crux of the
presentation and why we're here today to
talk about how do we drive
online lives uh through to offline
behavior
and really at our core
the tactic that we use is called
gamification
and what this essentially means is we're
using gaming tactics such as point bait
point-based currency or leveling
leaderboards
surprises when you know surprise and
delight when you're not expecting it
in a non-gaming environment
this is not something new uh
to uh the world of uh marketing
loyalty-based uh incentives have been
around for a long time if you think
about the airline industry and frequent
flyer programs or the credit card
industry and cash back you know it's a
mechanism in which we look to engage
participation to garner loyalty
and also to create that you know brand
affinity and emotional connection to
want to have that personal tie and to
keep coming back and to re and to keep
engaging with your product and services
i wanted to sort of you know provide a
bit of a
context in which gamification lives
so um really what has driven
gamification over the course of the last
say five to seven years really has been
technology and your mobile phone and
smartphones um you know this has really
driven it to a whole other level
um here are just a handful of examples
of those that i consider best in class
um in terms of using gamification
tactics
to me foursquare was really the um
you know the purveyor of uh gamification
tactics you know the idea of checking
into a place getting points for checking
into the place getting that feedback
loop of this is the first time you've
checked into yale university um you know
this is the you know be the first of
your friends to check into this place um
and you know really bring gamification
principles and tactics um in the mobile
location space
nike plus
really a thought leader and disruptive
in the apparel and fitness so really
bringing that feedback mechanism how
many miles you have run how many
calories what does that look like in
comparison to your peers um how is your
you know your newest pr how is that
compared to your peers and also setting
goals for yourself whether you want to
run a half marathon or marathon and
helping you get there
starbucks my starbucks rewards really
have made it so seamless
um and turned key and really i think
about this all the time in terms of i
never really have to think about um
where's that piece of paper or that
making sure that the the counter person
stamped it right and that you will see
and then keeping count of how many
coffees i've got so i get my next free
coffee really starbucks has made it so
turn-key and easy through their mobile
app
and you know they're constantly talking
to me constantly knowing like my my
favorite drink is a low-fat cappuccino
tall low-fat cappuccino and making sure
that you know that that you know when i
don't order it what's up why did i
decide to do that
and lastly i put up the example vagal so
all these uh in their day have been
disruptors within their within their
industry or vertical and viggle is a
newly launched app in which
in a place where you wouldn't
necessarily think you would need a
loyalty scheme and really that's in tv
so
tv itself is going through a
transformation
viewership is down people are just
getting content where they want to get
it and vigil has come up with a rewards
uh scheme using gamification in which
you check into the show that you watch
you get points for the show you get
certain points you get certain points
for certain shows and they also have a
live aspect in which you can play games
and answer questions and get more points
and then you can redeem those points for
rewards to
uh national and local retailers so these
are just a couple of examples and really
how recyclebank fits in there is really
doing it in terms of the sustainability
world
so our platform uh it's you know
three-fold it consists of a community
they can be your friends they can be
your neighbors and they can also be
people that are like-minded share the
values that you share
content
uh the content varies we have a um you
know a range of spectrum of depth from
daily tips whether it be on facebook or
on recyclebank.com to just sort of
easily incorporate and remember that
quick reminder uh of if you're shopping
for the most recent one was floors you
know make sure that you're thinking
about sustainable sourced uh you know if
you're doing wood floors sustainable
stores wood floors
two
two to three minute interactive
educational modules um currently we have
the uh a module up that is for earth
month
and it's based on a time capsule um and
so you know it's about
delivering the content in an engaging
relevant manner uh the 80s uh 80s module
just came up and i was taking it
yesterday and uh you know one of the
ways in which we uh make it memorable
and digestible is we had a quick tip on
or was take a pledge based on the launch
of diet coke and really the educational
element was really to get across that
aluminum is infinitely recyclable and to
always remember that so that you
remember that you uh recycle that your
cycle your aluminum can but the
association of the launch of the diet
coke and really outplacing tab in the
early 80s uh was a monumental so that
association to sort of make it relevant
in my mind and kind of remember when
diet coke came out uh for those of us
that remember the 80s
uh but you know and then also that
reminder to you know recycle my aluminum
cans
to then the commerce platform
and this really is our rewards
marketplace uh you know we have over
3000
local and national retailers in which we
partner with um and no deals and
discounts all the way from uh bed bath
and beyond uh to the local pizza shop
down from down from the corner and
really what we see is in this in this
trifecta we're able to overlay gaming
tactics on top of that
enable to really be able to move someone
down their journey
and as we have developed this one of the
key things that has really come across
is that brands are also looking to get
across their sustainability messaging so
this was the time for another video but
i will do the voice over essentially
so
many marketing brands in this day and
age are really trying to figure out the
sustainability world as well
they have worked very diligently on
their sustain on their supply chains to
make it more sustainable
many of their manufacturing or
infrastructure but there's only so much
they can actually do
when it's actually the consumer that has
the greatest impact and so they see us
as being able to leverage our platform
to be able to get out their
sustainability messaging
really be able to connect with consumers
to in an authentic and
an authentic way in an engaging way
through our gaming tactics
to be able to get their message across
first really increase awareness but then
also create that emotional connection
with brand affinity that someone is
along this journey with me just as you
know as i'm going through it as we
realize that no one is perfect
um and ultimately to deciding uh to
purchase intent for you know at shelf
making the decision for a more
sustainable greener product
sorry
so one of the key partners that we have
is essie johnson
and essentially you know they um
have an overarching corporate goal in
which they're looking to be landfill
neutral and so they saw this our
platform as a way to be able to engage
on a mass scale
to be able to help
fulfill this goal and so we set out last
year at the end of la or second half of
last year
and came up with the recycling challenge
um we
went out into 50 communities 50
individual communities so now so we were
in every state
and it was a competition in which
communities competed
to increase their recycling
and the highest participation ultimately
won
the recycling competition and the prize
at the end of the day was a hundred
thousand dollar grant for
community sustainability project
so as i mentioned we launched this last
year it ran over the course of six
months through december
and we just were able to recently
announce
oops announce our winner
and which was a community in red red
rocks
virginia
and what is
what is hard what is very heartening
about the whole project is one you're
getting out the awareness
to increase recycling and there was a
huge amount of participation ultimately
one of the goals was being able to see
if we were able to have sustained
behavior change over time uh the tactics
that we employed were both the
on-the-ground
launching of the campaign but we also
had this online aspect
which every month there was a
leaderboard that got updated
and there was a house in which
you could learn how to be greener in
each one of the different rooms and
every month a new room opened up and we
saw the sustained engagement over the
course of the six months as people came
back to not only report their recycling
but also learn how to be greener
and not only did we see this increase
awareness for scj and the their
sustainability initiatives but we also
saw the inter overlay of that
people who engaged with the module were
also more likely to then go order the
rewards that see of the s.a.j products
so as sort of as a win-win situation uh
both
for for everyone involved because not
only did we increase the awareness and
increase uh participation and engagement
there was also the play of purchase
intent as well
so you're probably asking yourself what
is red rocks
of virginia going to
to do with their hundred thousand dollar
grant
ultimately they have a community center
uh in their community and they are going
to be um using it towards solar so solar
panels uh to help uh provide energy for
that community center
so last but definitely not least uh and
something that i think about
almost all of my time is our members
ultimately uh what we're able to show um
and our goal is to really motivate the
offline behavior um and ultimately you
know as it says amplify
consciousness through our education and
skip incentives video
and ultimately we've seen success um in
changing recycling behavior both from
actual lifts in in recycling so on
average when we have no infrastructure
changes so nothing changes in the just
recycle bank rolls out into the
community we have an average lift of 5
to 15 percent
uh lift in recycling for that community
while uh you know this may not seem
overwhelmingly at the end of the day
what the the impact that this has on the
bottom line and
for these communities is
is
is
quite significant
also we have overlaid on that what consu
what members say um and 82 percent
report that since recycle bank uh has
launched it's been influential to
recycling them more so we both have the
actual uh
actual behavior as well as the stated
behavior
beyond that
we actually have proven results beyond
recycling so as i mentioned uh from the
upfront ultimately our goal is to drive
uh for you know greener actions in their
life
and you know through our engagement our
educational elements uh
we beyond recycling we see that we're
able to really begin to bring members
down that path uh to a greener lifestyle
so
80 percent report that recycle bank has
been influential and encouraging them to
take other green actions and 70 cent
report that recycle bank has provided
them with good information to be more
eco-friendly and what we have seen is
over the course of a year within our
program is members incorporating one
more green action into their life
we track members pretty closely from
entry into the program through their
entire life cycle
and it's just amazing to see the impact
that the
the education and the incentive base and
the taxes that we're using have to drive
them down their journey
so brands themselves marketing brands
also are interested in driving down this
path of sustainability
i wanted to talk to
today about an example from suave so
unilever is another one of our marketing
partners
and have has sustainability goals as
well
and ultimately they were really looking
to
uh you know get their feet wet i guess
pun intended um
uh as it relates to as the rates the
topic of water
and so we came up with their campaign uh
for turn off the tap
we it was a dual uh
way of which you could pledge one was
you could pledge to take a two minute
shorter shower
and the other pledge was to turn off the
tap while you lather
the ways that you could engage
and uh you know participate was there
was a quiz uh in which there was the
learning element and pretty much the
primary message that was driven was
about the economic savings of turning
off the water
you know suave felt and from the
research that we had at the time we felt
that that would be the primary uh driver
in terms of wanting to save water
so uh
ultimately actually what the results
result showed was we did we did some
follow-up uh with members who had taken
the pledge um to really ask them one had
they take you know had they taken the
pledge and then two if they had you know
uh you know why and if they hadn't why
not
um of the two pledges we ultimately saw
that taking a shorter shower was
overwhelmingly
a lot easier to incorporate into their
lives
pretty much they said that it was easy
for them to remember to for
for them to remember to do
turning off the tap
a little bit more disruptive into the
whole process of taking a shower and
thus less likely to be incorporated uh
incorporated into into their daily
habits
but what was most interesting is really
when we started to ask those people who
actually hadn't taken
uh the you know who had take the pledge
didn't didn't start taking the action
why hadn't they started and
overwhelmingly in both instances it
really was that time factor it was that
they didn't remember there was that
there was that no um
you know uh sort of signal to remember
to do that
and so ultimately what we saw
uh
this happened is it really led to
innovation for um unilever and suave in
particular
they brought this back to the drawing
board and really over the course of the
last year
i've really brought markets or products
to market to really address this
so
um one what they did was they along with
suave products for a limited time they
had included a timer it was called the
water pebble and it was out in walmart
uh for a limited time and really you
know be able to have something that was
tangible to remember to
you know put your timer on for for your
shower
secondly they developed a line a
two-in-one shampoo line for adults that
was particularly targeted
for men and it was a new launch product
for men and hope and you know that was
to help you know so they didn't have to
remember to do it but that just that
time savings would ultimately impact
water conservation um and last but not
least they also introduced dry shampoo
into their into their line um and really
helping to just
continually without you know messaging
of looking to save money wasn't going to
resonate so looking for other
alternatives and innovations in which
they could uh still drive towards that
goal of conserving water but a new and
in new ways
so ultimately um
you know in the 21st century we're
really faced with uh 20 you know 21st
century problems really need 21st
century movements
and where we see that is really the
intersect of you know technology and
social really being able to drive that
at our core
uh we believe that you know every little
step counts it's just you know being
able to make that uh make your journey
down that path um and every little um
action uh will actually have a
collective a greater impact
i'm in with that i'd like to open it up
to any questions
is there a mic
thank you for your talk it's very
enlightening um i have a question
regarding the at the very beginning of
our presentation about the data and how
much what the percentage of the items
are recycled so
i was wondering so far for the for the
thing i put in the recycle bin
how much is it is actually being
recycled
so 18 of materials are being recycled
but of the 100 that could be recycled so
for the so for all the
recycled like bottles
that i throw into the recycle bin like
outside
eighteen percent of that stuff is
written
so it's the consumer so in the household
of the total amount that you could
recycle only eighteen percent is
actually getting recycled so the large
majority is still ending up in the waste
bin are you saying 18 of the
uh the stuff that can be recycled is
actually recycled or
because my question is all about if i
have actually put things in the recycle
bin and the stuff was transported to the
recycled facilities yeah is that
everything in the recycle facility will
be recycled or there are still lots of
things kind of just hanging around in
their inventory because of the lack of a
lack of facility capacity to recycle
everything they receive
sure so yeah so everything i mean it's
very municipality community dependent
that's why some places take plastic
number fives and some don't so
everything that is being collected
through the recycling stream
that is brought to the murph would get
recycled typically it's sold on a
secondary market as the commodity market
and
and gets recycled
do you talk about recycling textiles at
all
sure so yeah actually i was just going
through some of our daily
daily tips and we had a daily tip um in
the last week just on uh
how to go about recycling uh textiles
you know it's not something uh in
particular that um you know it's sort of
up and coming so i know in new york city
um it has been a recent uh uh
addition into in which we can do it the
we it's not something that we can do
within our households we actually have
to bring it to certain areas certain
areas that take it such as the farmers
market
but we we do begin to address it uh in a
very broad reaching way um and then be
able to forward people on to
local information in which they would be
able to to do it
great thank you
um
over here
oh yep
do you do anything to
verify the self-reported claims of the
consumers say measure the the
water consumption or measure the waste
generation
to get beyond the self-reported surveys
yeah um so absolutely so um i mean
that's a lot of the research that i um
have a foundation in so
we um what we have seen through our
research
both from
because we do have non-self-reported
products as well is that uh people
report when they recycle
um there is very
little um gaming or or gaming of the
system or not doing it when you don't do
it seems to be a very inherent
behavior
and i think what really the success
about that is is that you are attaching
it to a behavior that's already
happening so
uh you go and you put your bin on the
curbside or you're putting it out
wherever you need to put it out you
think to go then report
so we see very little
difference between when we actually know
the pickup is and the amount of times
people
of self-report the system so much as
if you ask people do you turn off
the water
the answer could be yes even if they
don't do it every time or do you put the
stuff out of
the curve well
um how much of the recyclable material
are they actually capturing the
recycling effort right so
uh yes so we can't guarantee that it's
every time uh
however um i mean the it's about the
journey so even if you do it one last
time or
not as frequently as you
or as more frequently than you had
before um it's you know it's about a
process
nice talk mode
uh two questions one is is all of your
statistics
based on self-reporting or are you
looking at the whole landfill
percentages for a community no so um the
majority of our
reporting is actually
actual so we when we work with um
communities they will provide a baseline
recycling rate that they have and then
we actually the way that we can give the
way that we give points is when we know
we get the recycling weight based on the
community so
we have that data and that's we can look
at the delta between before and after
the the member perceived or report
self-reported is sort of a complementary
to that um but we rely heavily so
heavily on the the actual the white data
second question is the five to fifteen
percent lift that you um put on a slide
have you gone back um to any communities
to see a year later two years later to
see how sticky that is
um sure so i mean recycle bank uh was
launched initially in 2006 so we
actually have
eight eight seven years of data uh going
back and so it's an average over that
period of time that's not uh over that
period of time and it incorporates that
anything else
great thank you thank you so much
okay so um i guess that will be a
15-minute break and we'll join up here
again at 11 30 for a presentation by
josh dorfman of vine.com thank you all
you